[Applause]
Paul and punch oh oh that's the youngest
filemaker person among us let's do this
to the film I've seen it before in the
purest elements of storytelling I
thought that well first off thank you
everybody for coming to be honest I flew
back today partly to honor my grandma
who died at 106 as I mentioned last year
it was really cool to see her just as he
did see her scoring here and there with
an audience again I think that she and
Renfrew were the most interesting
characters to me because they each have
a change a lot the others are pretty
much set in their ways and are quite
good but um you could really see the
influence of theater and and silent film
on them and lack of competition from
television and and the Internet
but I think that there was something I'm
really unbridled about those two roles
in those two performances I found if I'm
sitting here and I've seen this two or
three times it's the use of silence yeah
by somebody sounds and we go to the
movies these days that it's it's
intriguing to sit through many long
sequences pure silence did it sound like
that in a theater originally or or as I
believe it did yes
and listen well there was no reason to
have a compliment with it because it was
a sound film and then there was a
punctuated by screaming yes which made
all the more frightening yes but what
came out of nowhere
Susan just to see your mother on the
screen you know a long time ago freedom
freedom of expression and she she
enjoyed what she was doing she laughed
at herself and she was a great
storyteller this audience might be
interested and one is by a memoir of is
a table outside as you leave sorry but
it's available it came out about five
years ago I think and it's available
both in English and in Spanish and the
other book you might be interested in is
by a man called David scowl skl and that
was published about 25 years ago it's
called Hollywood gothic and he devotes a
whole chapter to the making of this
version of dragon
and other versions of the play and her
father I'm sorry it was actually David's
comparison of the two versions
yes Bakula that caused Universal to try
to find a negative and a print one
missing real was in Cuba and they mm-hmm
restored the print and it has had a
great success I started going to film
festivals with my mother when 25 years
ago the first one was in United States
in Dallas Texas and Morland Chris came
from New York they must have been 15 and
17 and they showed this film on a huge
screen nipple bumps and all after it
said I understand why grandpa married
you I'll leave that to Chris I remember
being with you both in Guadalajara I
appeared with her three or four times
it's that this is nobody who has not
made a film in 60 years almost and
people were so taken with her and never
seen anything quite like that we I think
we had sort of two mothers in one I
remember as a child when we would go to
Mexico my mother was really a big
personality there were autograph hunters
photographers we'd go in a restaurant
and they would immediately play her
theme song from Santa yes and my father
was in the background
and then we come back here and my father
was the important figure in Hollywood
and our mother was just our mother
packing the lunches and Oh wake up was
it's quite a juxtaposition and her own
father was somewhat disapproving oh
right over over some of her roles little
grandma's Lupita's father was not the
case yes well he didn't but my
grandfather in Mexico was very stern and
old-fashioned he didn't want her to be
in the movie business at all and it was
almost a miracle that he actually let
her go with her Irish grandmother as her
chaperone and there were big fights
every time she go back to Mexico for
premiere ISM whatnot my grandfather
would throw her out of the house and and
yet she was helping them out and find
out oh yes yeah I'm bringing it up
because that sort of joy of life her own
story was to some degree her escaping
from a degree of I mean I imagine if she
hadn't become an actress and had to move
to to Los Angeles she she would have had
a very different experience I think she
was one of nine children the eldest of
nine and I was that line and then life
in Mexico City in Mexico and and the
late 1920s a woman was kept in the
kitchen and taking care of the other
children and married off and my mother
as she said herself she escaped and
traveled the world had a marvelous
marriage to a year pianist
Czechoslovakian a film maker also my
father produced 30 some-odd films she
had really an amazing life the two of
them did
yes the the the fact that she went she
came from Oaxaca knowing no English and
then she went to Germany to my Poland
Czechoslovakia knowing no German and you
have a story about knowing something the
Berlin museum event
yes actually by my father went in 1932
he was sent to Berlin to head up
universals productions and after six
months he sent for my mother they were
married and they lived there till late
35 my mother was Catholic and had a
Mexican Passport
my father was Jewish but he had an
American passport by then so he was sort
of safe but their language in common
became German he didn't speak Spanish he
didn't speak English very well so they
spoke German and then when they came
back to Hollywood all of the emigres is
their friends who came back here
filmmakers coffee klatches on Sunday at
our house was all in German Susie and I
had a German governess so we grew up
with Sherman first and we in Berlin at
the opening of the brilliant film Museum
about 1213 years ago we were invited and
as we were walking from the about summer
Platz to the Sony building I saw there
were a crowd of like 2,000 guests there
and I realized that my told my mother
you're gonna have to sing for your
supper tonight you're gonna have to talk
and but it was her turn to get up and
speak to everybody she said I'm gonna
try to do this in German and here we
were 7080 years later and she spoke in
fluent German for 20 minutes I was have
seen amazed say that neither poncho nor
I knew that our Paris
had accents until a very late age no one
ever lost about shoes sounds kinky but I
don't recollect which one right shoeless
jr. glad to hear that mom I was in my
hippie phase my not my smile I was
really happy watching this I didn't
bring my six-year-old Oh to the
screening about my 13 year old my 10
year old me think kids are here so don't
do this whatever I did kids yeah I was I
was fainting um being a rebellious I'm
sure I don't know what happened with me
I was shoeless and there was that you
and Chris arrived together and you had
an appointment with a studio the next
day and you had no shoes I believe that
yeah we used to come out here my brother
and I my brother was a wonderful
filmmaker I'm and we've each now we work
on things together but we direct
separately and he's not here because
he's filming me something in Argentina
right now actually but we used to come
out here and pack in about 100 meetings
in 2 3 or 4 days and it was actually
really amazing to be staying in in this
house with pictures of John Huston and
Ingmar Bergman and sort of friends and
clients of my own merits and
paintings better there and people who
had had crushes on my grandmother
Mexican artists that dress um and to go
be selling whatever we were trying to
make a living but the song I heard was
that she removed it falling apart shoes
that you had and sent yeah I think she
bought me some shoes yeah whenever I'd
have a career advice from my grandmother
whether it be you know should I should I
do this film or that she could always
say good job she was a worker and and
also I'm she gave the goe there was a
visit saying in my family some years you
buy the jewels some you did you sell
them leads into a lot of fears it goes
along would take the job but I look the
positive thing is that it was so clear
that um that both she and my grandfather
had found this profession which which
allowed them to be that rewarded
eccentricity and allowed them to be as
much themselves as they wanted to be
[Music]
together or remarkable they didn't speak
a common language when they met and yeah
and that she fell in with this pack of
European intellectuals essentially and
not Billy Wilder Lubitsch
and the keys here and people who had
been sort of thrown together in this
watershed of immigration she called me
and said I want you to take me to the
Goethe Institute I thought okay well
I'll be happy to do that and I didn't
know what the event was but it turned
out to be documents from the family
about a fund set up for the refugees
from Nazi Germany father and mother dead
and it's quite extraordinary
they helped support many people for a
long time the European film phone and
yes at 30s where those immigrants who
were here and already working would
contribute to a fund enabling more of
the mostly the film writers directors
actors Jewish to somehow escape and find
work here affidavits cash monies to help
them through the first year he was
ordered by the German government theme
was that of this something something and
he has a permanent room the Paul Kohner
papers in the museum and in Berlin the
film use him so he's been honored for
his people is it close to Halloween so
yes but the film played well with this
audience which is a tribute to a big way
actually yeah mom passed away just about
one year ago not at 106
but at 106 and a half yes it's like one
of those half years count it was just a
year or so before that when a reporter
had called her from Mexico City
was usually over at her house most the
time and took care of any interviewers
whatever but he talked to her apparently
for a long time about her career and the
fact that she had a birthday coming up
and he asked her over there she had any
trepidations about her age and she said
no you know maybe the normal ones and he
said well you don't have to worry
remember you were bitten by Dracula she
loved to say that that's what I think
that's a nice way to end so thank you
thank you Bob and thank you all
[Music]
[Applause]
you